when I looked at Twitter earlier this
morning I saw Michael Irvin trending I
clicked on it with a you know with a
sweaty palm then I found out it was
because he was going nuts on first take
then I turned it on and I'm like man
here and Steven a was so it was a fun
watch and I had to get her over on the
phone how are you are you there no just
again having hung with you in London
last week and then been with you on game
day morning at the meeting I know that
your voice has been a little dicey
lately are you are you okay did you
survive the the first taking today yeah
you know and went over and asked fun you
know everybody's here in cialis waiting
on that big game tonight was it and
everything so it was fun to be over
there it's getting good okay back to
where it's just when I rise up I just
but I'm okay now because I you know we I
know sometimes how to get a rise out of
you does Stephen a - cuz I think he was
pushing your buttons
Irv absolutely whenever you start
getting you know my child because don't
see the past the past the past they're
traveling you know and I got a raise on
that now you know and and what what I
have to tell people is don't allow
stupid and these guys to get you with
this they're selective retention of
history they like to talk about the 20
years and no playoff uh not much real
success but where she's going history
like the people say their courts open
all of the history up now you got to
talk about the five Super Bowl you can't
just select what history you want to
visit and I want to talk about it hmm so
what path are they on Michael can you
tell me what passes and what's the pass
well we had a 23 year old running back a
24 year old receiver in a 25 year old
quarterback three main positions you
guys solid at offensive line and you got
a great defense is playing great
football right now now he just got the
receiver so right now all you're talking
about is putting all of it together you
got all the tools you got all the tools
in your box dad's just got to pull out
the right tools at the right time
them correctly if you got some well let
me let me channel my inner Steven a
don't the guy I don't think I have much
of one because he's a unique he's a
unique dude but you don't think the
first round choice coughed up for Cooper
is preposterous ludicrous that you were
at bamboozled hoodwinked first round
pick my gopher Amari Cooper we we act
like first rounders or automatic gold we
are we were first round first round we
act like he's automatic gold you don't
know you don't know that guy's going to
be going to tell me the first round of
bus that we have had so now you're
saying put more into a first rounder
that you don't know as opposed to a
first rounder did you see a success in
this me that's been very young that
defect so you're not losing anything and
giving up a first round of for Amari
Cooper here's the first round in his
first round young if got a guy mix it's
going to be 21 22 years old so what do
you think he's gonna love it
what do you know what do you think he's
going to look like tonight what's the
key now kitty acquiring a talent is one
thing making sure you use it properly
and correctly that's another thing and
now the pressure falls on Scott Lena
here and the pressure fall in love that
Prescott to do something with that
talent it's one thing when you don't
have a talent and they're gonna have the
talent @y receiver
but there's one player upgrades that
home position because now he's a number
one you got an up-and-coming number two
there hopefully one day gonna turn into
a wine and gallo and by gallup and you
got some nice because like hundred bees
with to add to it now you got to receive
a receivers home that you can work with
michael irvin here in the Rich Eisen
show before i let you go or what you
think of Michael Thomas and the
cellphone the homage to Joe horn with
four minutes to go up ten what do you
think of that now now I am someone
creativity but but do a Brandon Rainey
arms and right there that could have
gotten scary because of the ramps if
they complete that one third down are
and if one fourth down and it cooks
doesn't drop that forth into you could
be talking about an opportunity that
you're gaining them to come back you
know but i'ma tell you so much
that's the kid that we don't mention in
the top five top top the top receivers
in this league and Michael Thomas is
certainly one of those with God
I thought he had fun last night and it
all worked out but don't slip on that
kid that's not bad for playing receiver
no I know he is he is I mean what he's
done is unbelievable you know when they
traded cooks if everyone's like why what
are they doing he's been remarkable all
right but you're just asking I mean why
would you give the Rams down ten a team
that score and come back from 21 down 15
extra yards after you've just put a
dagger in him and by the way the smell
of burnt toast with Marcus Peters from
that kid yesterday was quite something I
mean why would you do that yeah he had
set up in his mind and he said I know if
I get his opportunity aim imma do it and
he got a great opportunity seven yards
that was a great opportunity I
understand
be careful there but he probably thought
this game was over you know in his mind
and said I waited late in the game and
thank god it worked out the late in the
game so I knew once he once he was on
his way rich there's no way he was not
going to do it after he had already put
all those wills
into play but man man and that's another
things you brought up to Marcus Peters
reaching ready to stack the other day
that you were talking about some other
arena stat about how many 100-yard games
I've had it just Hall of Fame Hall of
Famers you know and all of that stuff
we're talking about that in meetings and
I was thinking about this shut down
corners that we have now in today's game
it's not like to shut down corners we
had been like now these shut down
corners get pinched it get burned like
we saw yesterday they get bench like
Josh if it blows my mind
you never heard or beyond Sanders Darryl
Greene aeneas was rock which you never
heard of them guys getting bench are
getting beat that bad unless they were
playing me of course
all right Irv are you are you still with
the NFL Network cuz I'm sure ESPN
doesn't want to let you out of the
building again I mean they already let
you out of the building once and you
just lit up
first take the trended not many guests
on first take trended are you still are
you still with us we still in us more
please rich you know my family is I'm a
hitter seller NFL all day that's what I
do but it don't ever worry I've never
leave at home okay no I know I mean we
had a nice moment in the 15th
anniversary I broke down on the set you
came out he kissed me on the head it was
you know I mean I can't I can't lose you
I can't and I said the truth rich I say
the truth I said it when I said well we
hope that the other place we were just
scared but over here rich a lot of
Pioneer started it you were here when
they open the doors and we appreciate it
anything is chrome and you've been there
since day one man and we love you and we
appreciate you being I was feeling will
and keep driving us well right into that
love you Michael ever oh do we have
Steven a on on his Amari Cooper tank
let us straight run amok and flat-out
deceit there you go how's them right
there okay can we make sure we use it
the right way
all right or if you take care well chat
soon good job as always is Michael Irvin
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience